There is a concept of data race that
plays an important role in considering how we can
relax consistency. A data race occurs when there is
a data dependence between accesses that are on different
cores, and the accesses are not ordered by synchronization.
So, for a data race to occur, we need
to really have one process rating and another writing
to the same variable. Or the other way around,
or both of them writing. And, the
access on this different course are not ordered
by synchronization. So, here's an example of
a data race. A data race here exists
because really we can have this happen or in another execution this store might
occur before the load and thus, this can happen too. So this is a data race.
In contrast, something like this, where we do load A, then a barrier, and this
thread participates in that barrier, and then thus
store A, there is a data dependence between
accesses but, they are clearly order by synchronization.
This one will happen before this one because
of the barrier synchronization, so there is no
data race here. Conceptually, our data race allows
any order of these operations and that
might change the outcome of the program, whereas
here we know what's going to happen. Then there is a concept of a data race free
program which is a program that cannot create
any data races in its execution. Pretty much
that program is considered to be well synchronized
so that any accesses to data are correctly
ordered by synchronization, barriers, locks, flags,
etcetera. A key property of data-race-free programs
is that they behave exactly the same as they would in sequential consistency,
even if we run them in any relaxed consistency model. Why is that
so? Well, because if your synchronization is
implemented correctly, then your synchronization is going to
create the right orderings for things, and then, there is no opportunity for the
re-orderings that might violate sequential consistencies. So
data-race-free program is actually sequentially consistent, even if
we run it on a machine that doesn't support sequential consistency as long as
synchronization is correctly implemented for that machine.
But keep in mind that while your debugging
your programs, even if you intend them to
be data race free, they may not actually
be data race free. In which case, theoretically,
anything can happen. So pretty much, while we
are debugging a program. To remove data races,
the behavior of that program on a weekly
consistent system might be very weird and thus
is makes the bugging really, really difficult. So for
most programs that are correct, and that means
data-race-free, we can relax the consistency model. But
for the debugging it really helps if we
can support sequential consistency. So some processors actually
have support to flip between sequential consistency, or
some more relaxed consistency that gives us better
performance. So that when you're debugging, you can
use sequential consistency until you're reasonably sure that
your program is working correctly and is data-race-free.
At which point, we can run it on a
weaker consistency model to benefit from the additional
re-ordering that the processor is now allowed to do.